This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Early one Monday this past December, Peter Dorfult started his week the way most of us do, which is to say, reluctantly. So it was a normal Monday morning, I was gonna go to work and I've only been awake for like half an hour or something, so I was still a bit woozy. Peter lives in Dresden, Germany, where he works in elder care, visiting clients at their homes.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。去年12月的一个周一清晨，彼得·多尔富特像我们大多数人一样开始了新的一周，也就是说，心不甘情不愿。那是一个平常的周一早晨，我正要去上班，当时我才醒了半小时左右，所以还有点迷糊。彼得住在德国德累斯顿，从事老年护理工作，负责上门探访客户。
And to do that, he usually takes the bus. But that morning, he noticed something unusual as he boarded. When I got on the bus, I see that the bus driver had put up a sign inside of the bus that said in German, Diesenbus steut Einddeutscher-Fahrler, which means this bus is driven by a German driver. A homemade sign saying this bus is driven by a German driver was not the kind of thing Peter was used to seeing on his daily commute. That's reporter Kevin Caner's.
为了工作，他通常会坐公交车。但那天早上，他上车时注意到了一些不同寻常的事情。当我上车时，我看到司机在车厢里贴了一张德语告示，写着“Diesen Bus steuert ein deutscher Fahrer”，意思是“这辆车由德国司机驾驶”。一张写着“这辆车由德国司机驾驶”的自制告示，并不是彼得在日常通勤中习惯看到的东西。这是记者凯文·卡纳的报道。
But Peter, the driver's message was pretty clear. I can only interpret what the person who put up the sign would have said. But the application to me was, this is a good bus, you do not have to worry, you can talk to me in German because I am one of the good ones. And not a foreigner. But what really drove the message of this sign home was not just the words, but the typeface they were printed in. A typeface from a larger family of typefaces once used throughout Germany and commonly
但对彼得来说，司机的意图很明显。我只能解读贴告示的人想表达什么。但给我的暗示是：这是一辆好车，你不用担心，你可以用德语跟我交流，因为我是“好人”之一，不是外国人。但真正让这张告示传达的信息深入人心的，不仅仅是文字，还有印刷这些文字的字体。这是一种源自德国各地曾广泛使用、通常被称为“Fraktur”（断裂体）的字体家族，在英语中它有另一个名字：黑体（Blackletter）。
referred to as Fracture, in which an English goes by a different name. Blackletter. Blackletter is the type of old, timey, gothic typeface that you often see used for the bold front titles of newspapers like the New York Times or Washington Post. You might also see it on Tattoos or the T-shirts of Heavy Metal bands. Put it on a page and it brings to mind the time of castles, nights, and feather quills. But for many people, especially in Europe, Black Letter is most closely associated with one thing. It's the Nazi font. You know, I'm not that good with history and stuff.
黑体是一种古老、陈旧的哥特式字体，你经常会在《纽约时报》或《华盛顿邮报》等报纸醒目的头版标题中看到它。你可能也会在纹身或重金属乐队的T恤上看到它。把它印在纸上，会让人联想到城堡、骑士和羽毛笔的时代。但对许多人，尤其是欧洲人来说，黑体与一件事联系最紧密。它是“纳粹字体”。你知道，我对历史之类的东西不太了解。
But what I know is that the font that was used by Nazi Germany really, really looks the same way as this. October 1938, Adolf Hitler made his triumph in entrance into Jefferson Revoculus, so date back. Just days earlier, the world was at the brink of war. The France and Great Britain reluctantly signed out to the Munich Act. If you've ever caught even one minute of the history channel or really any documentary about World War II, you have seen this typeface on Nazi posters, on Nazi office buildings, on Nazi road work signs, usually saying something
但我知道的是，纳粹德国使用的字体看起来确实和这个一模一样。1938年10月，阿道夫·希特勒凯旋进入苏台德地区，那是很久以前的事了。就在几天前，世界还处于战争边缘。法国和英国勉强签署了《慕尼黑协定》。如果你看过哪怕一分钟的历史频道，或者任何关于二战的纪录片，你一定在纳粹海报、纳粹办公大楼、纳粹道路施工标志上见过这种字体，通常写着类似“Verboten”（禁止）这样的话，后面还带着一个大大的感叹号。
like verboten with a big exclamation mark. Today in Germany, black letter typefaces are frequently used by neo-Nazi groups, and for many Germans, they bring to mind the dark times of the country's fascist past, which is why it was pretty clear to Peter and the other passengers on the bus what was going on with this bus driver's sign. The message by itself is not welcoming and has this nationalist tone, but the fun choice adds to that. Floyd Hartwig is a graphic designer in Berlin and the editor of a website called Fonsenuse. And he says that in Germany, when it's not being used on a bantee or a masthead, Black Letter has a very specific set of connotations.
如今在德国，黑体字经常被新纳粹团体使用，对许多德国人来说，它们会让人想起该国法西斯过去的黑暗时期，这就是为什么彼得和车上的其他乘客很清楚这位公交司机告示的含义。信息本身并不友好，带有民族主义色彩，而字体的选择更是加剧了这一点。弗洛伊德·哈特维格是柏林的一位平面设计师，也是“Fontenuse”网站的编辑。他说，在德国，当黑体字不是用在乐队T恤或报纸刊头上时，它有一套非常具体的内涵。
The Black Letter type phases, as a genre, have been associated with German nationalism for a long time, and everybody who sees them today knows that it's not a standard choice, it sends a signal emphasizing the Germaness. Even if it was like in a neutral fun, it would still have been a problematic thing, but it's kind of like the cherry on top, the one thing that really drives the point home. The sign that Peter saw that day would end up causing a big stir in Germany and get folded into an ongoing debate surrounding racism, nationalism, and culture, a debate in which the use of black letter often serves as a kind of symbolic dividing line.
黑体字作为一个类别，长期以来一直与德国民族主义联系在一起，今天看到它们的人都知道这不是一种标准选择，它发出了强调“德国性”的信号。即使它用的是一种中性字体，这仍然会是个问题，但黑体字就像是锦上添花，是真正把观点表达得淋漓尽致的那一点。彼得那天看到的告示最终在德国引起了轩然大波，并被卷入了一场围绕种族主义、民族主义和文化的持续辩论中，在这场辩论中，黑体字的使用往往充当了一种象征性的分界线。
Today, depending on one's perspective, black letter can either represent German cultures rich and proud heritage, or alternatively symbolize everything that's wrong with it. But to understand how people's feelings about a simple typeface got to this point, we need to go back to the moment of its birth. Because once upon a time, in that bygone era of knights and castles and feather quills, Blackletter wasn't limited to Germany. It wasn't even Germanic.
今天，根据个人的视角，黑体字要么代表德国文化丰富而自豪的遗产，要么象征着它所有错误的东西。但要理解人们对一种简单字体的感受为何会发展到这一步，我们需要回到它诞生的那一刻。因为曾几何时，在那个骑士、城堡和羽毛笔的久远时代，黑体字并不局限于德国。它甚至不是日耳曼语系的。
Instead, it was used all across Europe. Black Letter may seem incredibly ornate, like it was created for the sole purpose of turning letter forms into little individual flourishes of art. It definitely does not seem like a common means of communication. But back in the Middle Ages, black letter with its angular forms was actually considered practical, especially for monastic scribes copying out entire books by hand.
相反，它在整个欧洲都被使用。黑体字看起来可能极其华丽，仿佛是为了将字母变成一个个小小的艺术装饰而创造的。它看起来绝对不像是一种常见的交流方式。但在中世纪，黑体字及其棱角分明的形式实际上被认为是实用的，特别是对于那些手工抄写整本书的修道院抄写员来说。
Black letter initially developed in the Middle Ages because forms that had these kinds of angles were easier to write more rhythmically and correctly than rounded forms. Den Reynolds is an American type designer and historian who has been living in Germany for the last two decades. And he says that today we're used to type faces with perfectly rounded curves. Think of our O's, use peas and seeds.
黑体字最初在中世纪发展起来，因为具有这种角度的形式比圆润的形式更容易写得有节奏且准确。丹·雷诺兹是一位在美国生活了二十年的美国字体设计师和历史学家。他说，今天我们习惯了具有完美圆润曲线的字体。想想我们的O、U、P和C。
But while these shapes look easy enough to draw, if you're using a quill to draw out thousands of them, page after page, they're not. And then, just as now, readers valued standardization in the text. Every letter, even the rounded ones, had to look exactly the same. But it was hard for a monk copying out a long text to draw consistently perfect circles. So, black letter writing styles probably arose so that the products would be more even in their appearance and probably also faster to produce. If you were a scribe, it was a lot easier to produce all those o's and u's and c's out of a series of short straight lines.
但虽然这些形状看起来很容易画，如果你用羽毛笔画出成千上万个，一页接一页，它们就不容易了。当时和现在一样，读者重视文本的标准化。每个字母，即使是圆形的，也必须看起来完全一样。但对于一个抄写长文本的僧侣来说，画出始终完美的圆圈是很困难的。因此，黑体书写风格的出现可能是为了让成品外观更均匀，也可能生产速度更快。如果你是一名抄写员，用一系列短直线来写所有的O、U和C要容易得多。
The technique of using straight lines, instead of perfectly rounded curves, gave the letters a fragmented appearance, which is actually how Germany's most common form of black letter type would get its name, Fratour. That's the Latin term for broken, because the letter forms have these broken, angle curves. Black letter was first developed in France in the 12th century, but within a few hundred years it had become standard throughout Europe. It wasn't even really a stylistic choice. It was just what words looked like.
使用直线而不是完美圆润曲线的技术，使字母呈现出破碎的外观，这实际上就是德国最常见的黑体字形式“Fraktur”得名的由来。这是拉丁语中“破碎”的意思，因为字母形式有这些破碎的、有角度的曲线。黑体字最早于12世纪在法国发展起来，但在几百年内，它已成为整个欧洲的标准。这甚至不是一种风格选择。它只是文字看起来的样子。
It went on question. That was what people thought of when they thought of writing, when they thought of a text. Susan Reed is head of Germanic studies at the British Library, and she says that Blackletter became so ingrained in the culture that even after it stops being needed, people kept using it. And so when the printing press was introduced, most of the early typefaces were some variety of black letter typeface. As with so many big leaps in technology, the printing press started off by borrowing
它不容置疑。这就是人们想到写作、想到文本时所想到的。苏珊·里德是大英图书馆日耳曼研究部主任，她说黑体字在文化中根深蒂固，以至于即使在不再需要它之后，人们仍继续使用它。因此，当印刷机被引入时，大多数早期字体都是某种黑体字。正如许多技术上的重大飞跃一样，印刷机最初借鉴了之前的设计惯例，尽管新的操作原则使得这些惯例变得不必要。
heavily on the design conventions that came before it, even though the new operating principles made those conventions unnecessary. Even Gutenberg, the man who developed the first popular printing presses, was no exception. He went for a textura, a narrow, very angular blackletter typeface that was also used by scribes at that time. At first, the printing press appeared to only further cement black letter status as Europe's dominant form of writing, but soon it would be challenged by a very different kind of typeface.
即使是开发出第一台流行印刷机的古腾堡也不例外。他选择了“Textura”，一种当时抄写员也使用的狭窄、非常棱角分明的黑体字。起初，印刷机似乎只是进一步巩固了黑体字作为欧洲主流书写形式的地位，但很快它就受到了一种截然不同的字体的挑战。
Roman kind of rolls off the tongue. And trust me, you've definitely seen Roman type before too. It's the style of letter that's associated with Imperial Rome. But just like the letters chiseled onto the side of an ancient marble column, Roman letters are sparer and more vertical than their black letter counterparts. You'd also probably find them a lot easier to read, and there's a reason for that. The letters are instantly recognizable, as they look like the letters that we've been reading our entire lives. Today, almost all major Western-type faces are Roman. From Times New Roman to Ariel. Every time you open up Microsoft Word or Google Docs, you're using Roman type.
“Roman”（罗马体）这个词读起来很顺口。相信我，你肯定也见过罗马体。它是与古罗马相关的字母风格。但就像刻在古老大理石柱侧面的字母一样，罗马字母比它们的黑体对应物更简洁、更垂直。你可能也会发现它们更容易阅读，这是有原因的。这些字母一眼就能认出来，因为它们看起来就像我们一生都在阅读的字母。今天，几乎所有主要的西方字体都是罗马体。从“Times New Roman”到“Arial”。每次你打开微软Word或谷歌文档，你都在使用罗马体。
It's our era's black letter. It's just what writing looks like. Yes, I mean, it's a strange thing. People have asked, you know, why why fractured became the default typeface in Germany? And I always almost want to flip the question on its head and say, why did Roman become the default everywhere else when most printing started in black letter type? Roman script might have stayed lost to history, but right around the same time Gutenberg was printing black letter Bibles in Germany, something else was happening in Italy. Renaissance scholars were rediscovering ancient Roman texts. You had this rediscovery in the Renaissance of classical literature in the classical world, and classical letter forms were being brought back.
它是我们这个时代的黑体字。这就是文字看起来的样子。是的，我的意思是，这是一件奇怪的事情。人们问过，你知道，为什么Fraktur会成为德国的默认字体？我几乎总是想把这个问题反过来问，为什么当大多数印刷品最初使用黑体字时，罗马体却在其他所有地方成为了默认字体？罗马字体可能一直被历史遗忘，但就在古腾堡在德国印刷黑体圣经的同时，意大利正在发生别的事情。文艺复兴时期的学者们正在重新发现古罗马文本。你在文艺复兴时期重新发现了古典文学和古典世界，古典字母形式被带了回来。
Committed to bringing back the culture and wisdom of antiquity, Italian scholars began consciously developing their own Roman-style letters, which drew heavily on the classical forms they encountered. And so when they started printing classical texts, then they started using those as well. At first, Roman type was used strictly for texts written in Latin, the language of antiquity and the church. But pretty quickly, and for reasons that remain a little hazy, Roman type broke out of
致力于恢复古代文化和智慧的意大利学者开始有意识地发展他们自己的罗马风格字母，这些字母大量借鉴了他们遇到的古典形式。因此，当他们开始印刷古典文本时，他们也开始使用这些字体。起初，罗马体严格用于拉丁语书写的文本，即古代和教会的语言。但很快，出于一些仍然有点模糊的原因，罗马体打破了它的拉丁牢笼，并接管了一切。
its Latin cage and kind of took over. By the end of the 16th century, Roman type had become common in the written vernacular languages of France and Spain. England followed suit in the 17th century, the Netherlands and Sweden in the 18th. It had become the very same thing that Blackletter had been before. Eubiquitous and unquestioned. But even as Roman became the Western world's dominant form of writing, Germany and the German language stayed resolutely committed to Blackletter, an island of broken script in a sea of curves.
到16世纪末，罗马体已在法国和西班牙的方言书写中变得普遍。英国在17世纪效仿，荷兰和瑞典在18世纪效仿。它已成为黑体字曾经的样子：无处不在且不容置疑。但即使罗马体成为西方世界的主导书写形式，德国和德语仍然坚定地致力于黑体字，成为曲线海洋中破碎脚本的一座孤岛。
And it's mostly thanks to the best-selling author in the history of the German language, Martin Luther. The adventure is on! Martin Luther! Luther and the Protestant Reformation he set in motion in Germany through everything that had to do with Rome and the Catholic Church into doubt. And in the process, he gave German as a written language a big boost. Luther by writing so much and trying to write to a broad as possible audience really codified a lot of what written German was. Luther and other German Protestants were especially keen to distinguish German writing from the writing
这主要归功于德语历史上最畅销的作家马丁·路德。冒险开始了！马丁·路德！路德和他通过德国发起的宗教改革让所有与罗马和天主教会有关的事情都受到了质疑。在此过程中，他极大地推动了德语作为一种书面语言的发展。路德通过大量写作并试图写给尽可能广泛的受众，真正编纂了许多书面德语的内容。路德和其他德国新教徒特别热衷于将德语书写与天主教意大利的书写区分开来，他们认为后者是腐败的，甚至是邪恶的。这包括教会最喜欢的字体。因此，人们明确地将罗马体与教皇、天主教以及非德国的事物联系在一起。至少在路德编写圣经版本时，这是一个明确的愿望，即它们应该用德文字体排版，而不是罗马字体。
of Catholic Italy, which they saw as corrupt, even evil. And that included the church's favorite typeface. So there was an explicit casting of Roman type as being associated with the Pope and with Catholicism and things that were not German. And this was at least by the time Luther is getting to his Bible editions. This is an explicit wish that they be set in German type and not in Roman type.
（注：原文此处有重复，已合并逻辑）
But there was one German typeface in particular, which would end up being used more than any other. Fracture. Fracture came to be seen as uniquely German, almost as if it were imbued with special Germanic values. So much so that people would eventually refer to all German black letter typefaces as Fracture. This association of Fracture with all things good and Roman with all things bad, became so
但有一种特定的德文字体最终被使用得最多：Fraktur。Fraktur被视为独特的德国字体，几乎就像它被注入了特殊的日耳曼价值观一样。以至于人们最终将所有德国黑体字都称为Fraktur。这种将Fraktur与所有美好事物、将罗马体与所有坏事联系起来的观念变得如此强烈，以至于在路德的一些德语圣经版本中，像“愤怒”、“魔鬼”和“惩罚”这样令人不快的词被排版为罗马字体，以将其与文本其余部分（保持Fraktur字体）区分开来。后来的德语文本甚至走得更远。如果一个词中哪怕只有一部分是从其他语言借来的，也会应用这条规则。实际上，你会得到这些相当奇妙的东西：当有一个外来借词，比如有一个拉丁词干和一个德语后缀时，同一个词中的拉丁词干会用罗马字母印刷，而结尾则用Fraktur。
strong that in some of Luther's German Bible editions, unpleasant words like wrath, devil, and punishment were set in a Roman typeface to distinguish it from the rest of the text which stayed in Fractur. Later German texts would go even further. Applying the rule if even part of a word was borrowed from another language. And you actually get these rather wonderful things that where there's a foreign loan word that has say a Latin stem and a German suffix,
（注：原文此处有重复，已合并逻辑）
there's Latin stem within the same word, we'll be printed in Roman letters and then the ending in Fracture. So this is a clear break, typographically, on the page from Rome. And just as there wasn't going to be a reconciliation between Germany and Italy, there wasn't going to be a typographic reconciliation either. At first, Blackletter remained popular in many parts of Protestant Europe. But one by one, the other Protestant countries began to give in to the temptations of Roman type, until finally Germany was the lone holdout.
因此，这在页面上与罗马形成了一种清晰的排版断裂。正如德国和意大利之间不会有和解一样，排版上也不会有和解。起初，黑体字在许多新教欧洲地区仍然很受欢迎。但一个接一个，其他新教国家开始屈服于罗马体的诱惑，直到最后德国成为唯一的坚持者。
In part because unlike the people in those other Protestant countries, Germany remained a fragmented jumble of smaller states until the late 1800s. So Fractura came to be seen as one of the things holding German national identity together, especially in the 19th century, when the country was invaded by Napoleon. The Occupy in French had their Roman letters, and the Germans had Fractur. Germany, as a nation without nationhood, as a collection of small, quite fragmented states, needed these other symbols of national identity and I think this is when Fracture particularly becomes associated with Germany and the German language and German culture.
部分原因是，与其他新教国家的人民不同，德国直到19世纪末仍然是一个由较小邦国组成的破碎集合体。因此，Fraktur被视为维系德国民族认同的事物之一，特别是在19世纪，当国家被拿破仑入侵时。占领的法国人有他们的罗马字母，而德国人有Fraktur。德国作为一个没有国家地位的民族，作为一个由小型、相当破碎的邦国组成的集合体，需要这些民族认同的其他象征，我认为这就是Fraktur特别与德国、德语和德国文化联系在一起的时候。
Many came to believe that where there was no Fracture, there was no Germany, including the mother of Germany's greatest writer. Gertr's mother, she actually described Roman letters as fatal, as if they're almost sort of painful for her to read. And I think that's something that's often quoted as evidence of this naturalness of Fractura of Germany's greatest writer's mother, approved of it. In 1871, when Germany finally unified, Procturer became the official government typeface. And out of on Bismarck, the first chancellor,
许多人开始相信，没有Fraktur就没有德国，包括德国最伟大作家的母亲。歌德的母亲，她实际上将罗马字母描述为“致命的”，就好像阅读它们对她来说是一种痛苦。我认为这经常被引用作为Fraktur自然性的证据，因为德国最伟大作家的母亲认可它。1871年，当德国最终统一时，Fraktur成为官方政府字体。而第一任总理奥托·冯·俾斯麦是如此坚定的支持者，以至于他说他拒绝阅读任何不是用德文字体排版的德国书籍。但就在他们终于拥有自己的国家时，越来越多的德国人开始怀疑他们是否真的需要自己的字体。
was such a staunch supporter that he said he would refuse to read any German book, not set in German type. But right around the time they finally got their own country, a growing contingent of Germans began to wonder if they really needed their own typeface. Liberal, cosmopolitan, and future-facing, these Germans came to feel it was silly to keep using
（注：原文此处有重复，已合并逻辑）
letterforms from the Middle Ages. They began perishing for Germany to drop its beloved fracture and move to Roman type. Now, where people sort of in the spirit of progress and modernism who thought that this is crazy, we should be a more international country we're connected with, with our neighbors, you know, we have business ties and cultural ties.
自由、国际化且面向未来的德国人开始觉得，继续使用中世纪的字母形式是愚蠢的。他们开始敦促德国放弃其心爱的Fraktur，转而使用罗马体。现在，那些本着进步和现代主义精神的人认为这太疯狂了，我们应该成为一个更国际化的国家，与邻国保持联系，你知道，我们有商业联系和文化联系。
Increasingly, academic and scientific papers intended for foreign distribution were being printed in Roman type. And as the world became more international, Roman type also started seeping in. It began to be taught in schools alongside Fractur, and by 1891, about 40% of German books were being printed in Roman. But more conservative Germans pushed back. They insisted that Blackletter was and should remain a cultural staple. In 1911, the German Reichstag actually held a vote on whether the country should switch
越来越多的旨在对外发行的学术和科学论文开始用罗马体印刷。随着世界变得更加国际化，罗马体也开始渗透进来。它开始在学校里与Fraktur一起教授，到1891年，约40%的德国书籍是用罗马体印刷的。但更保守的德国人进行了反击。他们坚持认为黑体字是且应该保持为一种文化主食。1911年，德国国会实际上就国家是否应该在学校和政府办公室用罗马体取代Fraktur作为官方字体进行了投票。
over by having Roman replace Fractur as the official typhoon in German schools and government offices. But after a fierce debate, the legislation didn't pass. German typography had reached a stalemate with neither side willing to budge. Even by the end of the 1920s in the era of telephone, radios, refrigerators, and jazz, traditional fructour street signs could be seen hanging next to art, deco posters featuring Sansaer of Roman fonts. It was a dual thing. If you look at photographs from the cityscape in the 1880s,
但在激烈的辩论之后，该立法没有通过。德国排版陷入了僵局，双方都不愿让步。即使到了20世纪20年代末，在电话、收音机、冰箱和爵士乐的时代，传统的Fraktur街道标志仍然可以看到挂在带有装饰艺术风格海报的罗马字体旁边。这是一种双重事物。如果你看1880年代的城市景观照片，在1980年代，你会看到这两种形式，甚至可能更多是罗马体，因为那是与商业和广告相关的风格。就好像有两个独立的排版现实代表了两个不同的德国。Fraktur最终会输掉这场为德国灵魂而战的斗争，但最终打破僵局的并不是那些自由、热爱自由、受过高等教育的国际主义者。相反，它是历史上最狂热的德国民族主义者。
in the 1980s, you would see both that of forms and maybe even more on Roman type, because that was the style associated with commerce and advertising. It was as though there were two separate typographical realities representing two different Germany's. Faktur would end up losing the struggle for Germany's soul, but it wasn't the liberal freedom-loving overeducated cosmopolitan who finally broke the impasse. Instead, it was the most ardent German nationalist of all time.
（注：原文此处有重复，已合并逻辑）
In 1933, the Nazi Party rose to power on a wave of German chauvinism. And at first, this seemed like great news for those in favor of traditional black-letter was in. Roman was out. There was a lot of push from certain areas within the government and within the party to use the moment in 1933 to random this change through to get rid of Roman type and really make everything be black letter. Directors were given in the interior ministry. That said, from now on, they would use black letter type letters for everything. Many publishers changed over. And the proportion of books and newspapers printed in Fractura type grew substantially. And you see plaque arts that tell Germans to be German, to think German, to even be German in their writing.
1933年，纳粹党在德国沙文主义浪潮中上台。起初，这对那些支持传统黑体字的人来说似乎是个好消息。罗马体被淘汰了。政府和党内某些领域有很大的推动力，利用1933年的时刻来强行推动这一变革，摆脱罗马体，真正让一切都变成黑体字。内政部下达了指令。这意味着，从现在起，他们将在所有事情上使用黑体字。许多出版商进行了转换。用Fraktur字体印刷的书籍和报纸的比例大幅增长。你会看到海报告诉德国人要成为德国人，要像德国人一样思考，甚至在写作中也要成为德国人。
And of course these are in Fractura. There was just one problem. Out of Hitler, I'm going to hate it, Fractura. just one problem. Out of Hitler, he had a hated fructour. I see something like this. In 1934, he actually made a speech in which he criticized the obsession without trappings of Germanness, among which he included gothic he writing. This gothic romanticism, Hitler says, is ill-suited to our age of iron glass and steel.
当然，这些都是用Fraktur写的。只有一个问题。希特勒，他讨厌Fraktur。我看到类似这样的东西。1934年，他实际上发表了一次演讲，批评了对“德国性”外在表现的痴迷，其中包括哥特式书写。希特勒说，这种哥特式的浪漫主义不适合我们这个钢铁和玻璃的时代。
It wasn't that Hitler wasn't into traditional German values. He just didn't think that should mean being old fashioned. It's hard to have everyone living in the mountains on farms with their cows and their sheep and their goats, and also working factories to build high-take airplanes and rockets. And when the Olympics came to Berlin in 1936, he insisted that a lot of the publicity and the posters and foot for that should be in Rome and rather than fracture a type because you were bringing the world to see the new Germany.
并不是说希特勒不喜欢传统的德国价值观。他只是认为那不应该意味着过时。很难让每个人都住在山上的农场里，养着牛、羊和山羊，同时又在工厂里制造高科技飞机和火箭。当1936年奥运会在柏林举行时，他坚持认为很多宣传、海报和字体应该使用罗马体而不是Fraktur，因为你要把世界带来看新的德国。
Besides, Hitler thought his fascist values shouldn't just apply to Germans. The Third Reich was supposed to span the globe. Hitler actually said that German was becoming the world language and within a hundred years everybody would be speaking German. But even Hitler's delusions of grandeur had their limits. He knew that if he wanted to rule over the world, he would have to use a typeface that the rest of the world could actually read. And so, in 1941, an edict was circulated
此外，希特勒认为他的法西斯价值观不应该只适用于德国人。第三帝国应该跨越全球。希特勒甚至说德语正在成为世界语言，一百年内每个人都会说德语。但即使是希特勒的宏大妄想也有其局限性。他知道，如果他想统治世界，他就必须使用一种世界其他地方真正能读懂的字体。因此，1941年，一份法令被分发给所有出版商和印刷商。
to all publishers and printers on behalf of the Fuhrer himself, decreeing that Roman type become the standard type throughout Germany. Effective immediately, neither a fructour, nor its cursive counterparts were to be taught in schools, used in government documents, or appear on street signs.
代表元首本人，下令罗马体成为整个德国的标准字体。立即生效，Fraktur及其草书对应物不得在学校教授、在政府文件中使用或出现在街道标志上。
All magazines and newspapers were likewise expected to change over to the Roman script. Which is quite an extraordinary thing to do in the middle of a world war, because it's very expensive to just suddenly go over from one type face to another, university. And the explanation in the letter is that, you know, shock, horror, they had found out that black letter was actually a Jewish invention, and that it had to be dropped immediately. This wasn't true, but it was an unassailable argument.
所有杂志和报纸也同样被要求改用罗马字体。这在世界大战期间是一件非常了不起的事情，因为突然从一种字体转换到另一种字体是非常昂贵的。信中的解释是，你知道，震惊，恐怖，他们发现黑体字实际上是犹太人的发明，必须立即废除。这不是真的，但这是一个无法反驳的论点。
It was impossible to come back from that. Fractured didn't finish everywhere overnight, but with the edict, it quickly fell out of use, and it would never fully recover. The Nazis brought in two black letters, 800-year-run, as a common form of writing. So it's ironic that the typeface Hitler banned and personally disliked, remained stubbornly associated with them.
从那以后就无法回头了。Fraktur并没有在一夜之间在各地消失，但随着法令的颁布，它很快就不再被使用，并且永远无法完全恢复。纳粹将黑体字作为一种常见的书写形式引入了800年。所以讽刺的是，希特勒禁止并个人不喜欢的字体，却顽固地与他们联系在一起。
Perhaps it's because the Nazis promoted Fractor so heavily before changing course, but it's also just because they were German nationalists, and it was a traditional German typeface. Maybe it shouldn't be surprising that they found it hard to shake the connection. Especially telling was the edict itself, the one banning Fractor. Although the memorandum was typed in a Roman font, the Nazi letterhead at the top was printed in black letter. By 1945, when Germany was finally defeated,
也许是因为纳粹在改变方针之前大力推广Fraktur，但也仅仅是因为他们是德国民族主义者，而这是一种传统的德文字体。也许他们发现很难摆脱这种联系并不令人惊讶。特别能说明问题的是法令本身，即禁止Fraktur的那份。虽然备忘录是用罗马字体打印的，但顶部的纳粹信笺却是用黑体字印刷的。到1945年，当德国最终战败时，
no one wanted anything to do with the quote-unquote Nazi font. And by the 1950s, it had pretty much died out. I think I saw some statistic that between 1951 and 1979, there was something like 34 books published in Fracture in that whole period, so that's quite astonishing. Whether or not it's okay to use block letter today is a complicated question, especially in Germany. It depends on the context, and it doesn't always make sense.
没有人想和所谓的“纳粹字体”有任何关系。到了20世纪50年代，它基本上已经消亡了。我想我看到过一些统计数据，在1951年到1979年之间，整个时期只有大约34本书是用Fraktur出版的，这相当令人震惊。今天使用黑体字是否合适是一个复杂的问题，尤其是在德国。这取决于语境，而且并不总是说得通。
Yeah, a factor on a restaurant sign or on a beer label is invisible and you can find better-the-mastheads on newspapers like New York Times, because that's normal. That's what we used to. Consumer items and commercial ventures that want to evoke a more innocent sense of tradition and quality, often use black letter without any trouble. The same goes for heavy metal bands and other people that want to play up its medieval or gothic qualities. But there are also contexts where its use is not innocent and can't be forgiven as naive. When Peter Dürrfel, the bus writer in Dresden, saw that sign, the one that said, this bus is driven by a German driver, it was printed in black letter, and Peter knew exactly what it was meant to communicate.
是的，餐厅招牌或啤酒标签上的Fraktur是隐形的，你可以在《纽约时报》等报纸上找到黑体刊头，因为那是正常的。那是我们习惯的。想要唤起一种更纯真的传统和品质感的消费品和商业企业，经常会毫无问题地使用黑体字。重金属乐队和其他想要发挥其中世纪或哥特式品质的人也是如此。但也有一些语境下，它的使用并不无辜，也不能被视为天真而原谅。当德累斯顿的公交车乘客彼得·多尔富特看到那张写着“这辆车由德国司机驾驶”的告示时，它是用黑体字印刷的，彼得清楚地知道它意味着什么。
Like, if I were a person that was potentially targeted by potential Nazis, I would definitely take the next bus. In fact, the side of the sign, and of the font, was so alarming that there was no way he could just let it go. So, I was thinking, I said, and of the font, was so alarming that there was no way he could just let it go. So I was thinking to myself, what should I do, should I? Like, talk to the guy, what? I didn't know what to do. But then I thought, wait, this is an official public bus.
就像，如果我是一个可能被潜在纳粹分子盯上的人，我肯定会坐下一班车。事实上，告示和字体的出现是如此令人震惊，以至于他无法就此罢休。所以我心想，我该怎么办？我应该跟那个人谈谈吗？我不知道该怎么办。但后来我想，等等，这是一辆官方的公共汽车。
I don't think that's even legal. When Peter got off the bus, he took a picture of the homemade sign on his phone and tweeted it at the Dresden Public Transit Authority, asking essentially, what the hell is this? And they responded like really quickly half an hour later and they were like, yeah, somebody already told us that, we don't know how that could happen, we already took the sign down and the bus driver will not be driving today anymore. So I was like, all right, thanks for the quick answer, good thing. And I thought that was it.
我不认为这甚至是合法的。当彼得下车时，他用手机拍下了那张自制告示，并推特给了德累斯顿公共交通管理局，本质上是在问：这到底是什么鬼东西？他们很快就在半小时后回复了，他们说：是的，已经有人告诉我们了，我们不知道怎么会发生这种事，我们已经把告示取下来了，那位司机今天不会再开车了。所以我说，好吧，谢谢你们的快速回复，很好。我以为事情就这样结束了。
But a little later a journalist message Peter on Twitter. And it's like, hey, I'm with the press. Do you want to do an interview? I'm like, okay, sure. And from there on, it just kind of spiraled. The story appeared on the local news, then on the national news. When the driver was let go, some German nationalists wrote tweets in the driver's defense. Then some some right-wing politicians retreated it, then I got some hate mail.
但过了一会儿，一位记者在推特上给彼得发了信息。他说：嘿，我是媒体的。你想接受采访吗？我说，好吧，当然。从那时起，事情就开始失控了。这个故事出现在当地新闻上，然后是全国新闻。当司机被解雇时，一些德国民族主义者在推特上为司机辩护。然后一些右翼政客转发了它，然后我收到了一些仇恨邮件。
In the end, it took a couple of weeks for everything to die down, although that doesn't mean the larger issues swirling around for a tour are anywhere near resolved. All right nationalism remains on the rise in Germany, and especially since the refugee crisis, controversy surrounding the use of the typeface seem to be happening with more frequency. No mainstream conservative politician publicly uses Fractur, but in 2017, a police anti-terror unit in the state of Saxony was sanctioned for using a logo on the interior of one of their specialized vehicles that featured a black litre font. Mostly though, the only people openly using
最终，事情平息下来花了几周时间，但这并不意味着围绕Fraktur的更大问题得到了解决。右翼民族主义在德国仍然在抬头，特别是在难民危机之后，围绕这种字体使用的争议似乎发生得更加频繁。没有主流保守派政客公开使用Fraktur，但在2017年，萨克森州的一支警察反恐部队因在其一辆特种车辆内部使用带有黑体字标志的Logo而受到制裁。不过，大多数情况下，唯一公开使用Fraktur的人是那些宣扬其超传统德国民族主义版本的新纳粹团体。显然，他们中的大多数人仍然没有意识到希特勒认为他们最喜欢的字体是无可救药的俗气和狭隘。而且许多民族主义者甚至不明白他们使用的是哪种字体。例如，德累斯顿的公交司机，
Fracture are neo-Nazi groups promoting their hyper-traditional version of German nationalism. Apparently, most of them still don't realize that Hitler considered their favorite typeface hopelessly tacky and provincial. And many nationalists don't even understand which typeface it is they're using. The Dresden bus driver, for example,
（注：原文此处有重复，已合并逻辑）
may have thought his sign was in Fractur, but it was actually in Old English, a black letter typeface that has no historical connection to Germany. Of course, if Peter's story about the bus driver and his black letter sign demonstrates anything, is that no matter what the real historical facts are, Fractur will never return to the mainstream.
可能以为他的告示是用Fraktur写的，但实际上它是用“Old English”（古英语体）写的，这是一种与德国没有任何历史联系的黑体字。当然，如果彼得关于公交司机和他的黑体字告示的故事证明了什么，那就是无论真实的历史事实是什么，Fraktur永远不会回到主流。
For better or worse, it's going to keep on being the Nazi font. This long tradition of centuries of use is kind of forgotten, and all we can see now are these 12 years of Nazis. And yeah, you can't change that. It has happened, and that's the way it is, and it won't come back. But even if they don't think it's a return to everyday use, those who study Proctor don't want to see it completely forgotten either. And perhaps, no one more so than Hanoblom.
无论好坏，它将继续成为“纳粹字体”。这几个世纪以来的悠久传统被遗忘了，我们现在能看到的只有这12年的纳粹历史。是的，你无法改变这一点。它已经发生了，事实就是这样，它不会回来了。但即使他们认为它不会回到日常使用，那些研究Fraktur的人也不希望看到它被完全遗忘。也许，没有人比汉诺·布洛姆更希望如此。
Hanoblom is a 76 year old retired teacher and is the president of the Association for German Script and Language, which is dedicated to preserving and improving people's knowledge of Fractura and other old writing styles. He says that the fact that neo-Nazis use black letter typepaces only shows that they know nothing about Germany's history. In much ofTS WISEN! Do you listen to me? In much of this historical ignorance is for a deeply ironic reason. Most Germans have trouble reading older German documents precisely because they are in Prok tour.
汉诺·布洛姆是一位76岁的退休教师，也是德国文字与语言协会的主席，该协会致力于保护和提高人们对Fraktur和其他旧书写风格的了解。他说，新纳粹分子使用黑体字只能说明他们对德国的历史一无所知。在很多历史无知中，有一个深刻的讽刺原因。大多数德国人很难阅读旧的德语文件，正是因为它们是用Fraktur写的。
You could probably read something printed in Prok tour, but even then only with a bit of effort and patience. And handwritten Prok tour is much more difficult. It's basically illegible for most people today. As a consequence, many of the books and letters and diaries of the past have become harder to connect with. Which is why one of the association's main activities today and the one Hano is most passionate about
你可能能读懂用Fraktur印刷的东西，但即便如此，也需要一点努力和耐心。而手写的Fraktur要困难得多。对于今天的大多数人来说，它基本上是无法辨认的。因此，过去许多书籍、信件和日记都变得更难与人产生联系。这就是为什么该协会今天的主要活动之一，也是汉诺最热衷的活动，
is teaching children how to read and write old German cursive. During our interview, he shows me some correspondence ... from the 19th century. Whose handwriting I can't make header tails of. And I say, that looks hard. For me, it's just that thing. See, see, they would learn that very quickly. But Hanno, that shows me I'd learn fast.
是教孩子们如何阅读和书写旧德语草书。在我们的采访中，他给我看了一些19世纪的信件……我看不懂那是谁的笔迹。我说，那看起来很难。对我来说，就是那样。看，看，他们会学得很快。但汉诺，那向我展示了我学得很快。
Yeah. Very fast. That I'd be amazed at myself. Yeah, they would be amazed. Hano hopes documents like this one will help people avoid making the mistakes of previous generations. After all, at 76, he is old enough to have lived through the war. When, as a small child, his city was destroyed in a bombing raid, and his family had to be evacuated.
是的。非常快。我会对自己感到惊讶。是的，他们会感到惊讶。汉诺希望像这样的文件能帮助人们避免犯前几代人的错误。毕竟，76岁的他已经老到经历了那场战争。当他还是个小孩子时，他的城市在轰炸中被摧毁，他的家人不得不撤离。
Who would not know where he came from? So he tells me how important it is that we learn from history. He also does not know what direction he should go. About war and peace, and about how to get along, and about the Germans of the past, like Luther and Gota, who wrote about all these things, and mostly, in fact, tour. Culture wars and fights about nationalism aren't just for fonts. We have these arguments about buildings too. We're talking about making federal buildings beautiful again after this.
谁会不知道他来自哪里？所以他告诉我，我们从历史中学习是多么重要。他也不知道他应该往哪个方向走。关于战争与和平，关于如何相处，以及关于过去的德国人，比如路德和歌德，他们写了所有这些事情，而且大多是用Fraktur写的。文化战争和关于民族主义的争论不仅仅是为了字体。我们也有关于建筑的争论。接下来我们将讨论让联邦建筑再次变得美丽。
As we were producing the story of Fracture and its starting role in this centuries-long drama of German nationalism, a contemporary story hit the news that was also at the intersection of design and nationalism. In this case, the story was about the architecture of U.S. federal buildings. On February 4, 2020, architectural record published a story commenting on a draft of an executive order that they got a hold of that called for the White House to adopt federal guidelines to ensure that, quote, the classical architectural style shall be the preferred and default style when it came to new and upgraded federal buildings.
当我们制作关于Fraktur及其在德国民族主义这场长达几个世纪的戏剧中扮演的角色时，一个当代故事登上了新闻，它也处于设计与民族主义的交汇点。在这个案例中，故事是关于美国联邦建筑的建筑风格。2020年2月4日，《建筑记录》发表了一篇报道，评论了他们获得的一份行政命令草案，该草案呼吁白宫采用联邦指导方针，以确保“古典建筑风格应成为新建和升级联邦建筑的首选和默认风格”。
The order was authored by a group called the National Civic Art Society and it was titled Making Federal Buildings Beautiful Again. In case you were at all confused as to the audience that this particular order was pandering to. Our friend, the architecture critic and celebrated McMansion skeptic, Kate Wagner, wrote a column in the New Republic about it and I called her up to talk about it. The first
该命令由一个名为“国家公民艺术协会”的组织撰写，标题为“让联邦建筑再次美丽”。以防你对这个特定命令迎合的受众感到困惑。我们的朋友，建筑评论家和著名的“麦克豪宅”怀疑论者凯特·瓦格纳在《新共和》杂志上写了一篇专栏文章，我打电话给她谈论这件事。我做的第一件事
thing I did was ask her what the authors of this order mean when they say that all federal buildings should be in the classical architectural style. So it's kind of funny, there idea of what classicism is is basically just anything inspired by Greek and Roman architecture, but also like 19th century Victorian catches fine too because they included the Eisenhower building which is this ridiculous Second empire building with like a million columns and I hate it so much and it's so ugly But they're like this is great architecture Well for the record I kind of like the Eisenhower building It's pretty fussy and very French
就是问她，当这份命令的作者说所有联邦建筑都应该采用古典建筑风格时，他们是什么意思。这很有趣，他们对古典主义的看法基本上就是任何受希腊和罗马建筑启发的东西，但也包括19世纪的维多利亚风格，因为他们把艾森豪威尔大厦也包括进去了，那是一座荒谬的第二帝国建筑，有上百万根柱子，我非常讨厌它，它太丑了。但他们说这是伟大的建筑。好吧，记录在案，我其实有点喜欢艾森豪威尔大厦。它非常繁琐，非常法式。
But the point is that when people extol the greatness of classical architecture, they're basically talking about columns. Yep, they're basically talking about columns. This broad advocacy for classical architecture is in opposition to more modernist or brutalist styles. They believe that modernism is degenerate and it's ruining everything and people hate it. And we need to free people from modernism because it's not the architecture of the people or whatever, which is of course ridiculous. How many people go to see falling water literally every year, I don't know.
但重点是，当人们赞美古典建筑的伟大时，他们基本上是在谈论柱子。是的，他们基本上是在谈论柱子。这种对古典建筑的广泛倡导与更现代主义或粗野主义的风格相对立。他们认为现代主义是堕落的，它正在毁掉一切，人们讨厌它。我们需要把人们从现代主义中解放出来，因为它不是人民的建筑，等等，这当然是荒谬的。每年有多少人去看“流水别墅”，我不知道。
So this proposed order is a 180-degree reversal to a seminal document written in 1962 by Daniel Patrick Moynihan called Guiding Principles for Federal Architecture that explicitly stated, quote, design must flow from the architectural profession to the government in not vice versa. Yeah, so there is basically a mandate in that document that's an official architectural style must be avoided and that federal buildings and that new buildings should be exemplary of the time in which they are built, the opposite in spirit to the proposed executive order. The architecture community reacted very strongly to this proposal and I should stress here
因此，这项拟议的行政令与丹尼尔·帕特里克·莫伊尼汉（Daniel Patrick Moynihan）在1962年撰写的一份开创性文件《联邦建筑指导原则》（Guiding Principles for Federal Architecture）背道而驰。该文件明确指出，引用原文：“设计必须由建筑行业流向政府，而非反之。”是的，该文件中基本上有一项规定，即必须避免使用官方建筑风格，联邦建筑和新建筑应成为其建造时代的典范，这在精神上与拟议的行政令背道而驰。建筑界对此提案反应非常强烈，我应该在这里强调，
that this is not an official proposal from the White House. It's a draft of a proposal that one influential group hopes the White House will adopt, but people have taken it very seriously. The American Institute of Architects released this statement, quote, The AIA strongly opposes uniform-style mandates for federal architecture. Architecture should be designed for the specific communities that it serves, reflecting our rich nations' diverse places, thought, culture, and climates.
这并非来自白宫的官方提案。这只是一个有影响力的团体希望白宫采纳的提案草案，但人们对此非常重视。美国建筑师协会（AIA）发表了如下声明，引用原文：“AIA强烈反对对联邦建筑实行统一风格的强制规定。建筑应为所服务的特定社区而设计，反映我们国家丰富多样的场所、思想、文化和气候。”
Architects are committed to honoring our past, as well as reflecting our future progress, protecting the freedom of thought and expression that are essential to democracy." Beyond the codification of one federal style, the architecture community objected to one aspect of the order in particular. This order would allow Trump to create a, quote, President's Committee for the Rebeautification of Federal Architecture, which is such a trolley name, and which would enforce this classical design mandate. And this panel would exclude, quote, artists, architects, engineers, art or architecture
建筑师致力于尊重我们的过去，同时也反映我们未来的进步，保护民主所必需的思想和表达自由。”除了将一种联邦风格编纂成法典外，建筑界还特别反对该行政令的一个方面。该行政令将允许特朗普创建一个“总统联邦建筑美化委员会”（President's Committee for the Rebeautification of Federal Architecture），这个名字简直是在挑衅，它将强制执行这种古典设计要求。而且，该委员会将排除“艺术家、建筑师、工程师、艺术或建筑
critics, members of the building industry or any other members of the public that are affiliated with any interest group or organization, involved in architecture. So basically anyone who works in architecture has anything to do with architecture like is not allowed to comment on architecture in this panel. So of course everyone is mad.
评论家、建筑行业成员或任何其他与建筑相关的利益集团或组织有关的公众成员。”所以基本上，任何从事建筑工作或与建筑有任何关系的人都不允许在这个委员会中对建筑发表评论。所以当然，每个人都很生气。
The AI is mad. The preservationists are mad. Kate Wagner, the, everyone is mad. The AIA is mad. The preservationists are mad. Kate Wagner, the architecture critic is mad. The objection from the architecture community, including yourself, is not an objection to classical architecture, right? No. Classical architecture is great. Ever since architecture has existed, there have been architectural revivals of past styles.
美国建筑师协会（AIA）很生气。保护主义者很生气。凯特·瓦格纳（Kate Wagner），每个人都很生气。AIA很生气。保护主义者很生气。建筑评论家凯特·瓦格纳很生气。建筑界（包括你自己）的反对意见并不是针对古典建筑本身，对吧？不。古典建筑很棒。自从建筑存在以来，就一直有对过去风格的建筑复兴。
I mean, it is a debate that frames the history of architecture, and the debate is constantly, is commonly known as the ancients versus the moderns. And that debate is like a healthy debate. It's a healthy debate. It's like, it's part of architecture, it's part of culture. Yeah, exactly. Like, when do we look towards the past for architectural ideas and when do we push forward through various integrations of those ideas together in the sort of eclectic mash or like furthering like technological progress?
我的意思是，这是一个构建了建筑历史的辩论，这场辩论通常被称为“古人与今人之争”。这种辩论是一种健康的辩论。这是一种健康的辩论。它是建筑的一部分，是文化的一部分。是的，完全正确。比如，我们何时从过去寻找建筑灵感，何时通过这些思想的各种整合，以某种折衷的混合方式或推动技术进步来向前迈进？
I mean, it's like one of the classic debates of architecture. But the thing is, is that classicism is, I mean, classical buildings are beautiful, obviously. And it's important that architects be trained in classicism. It's important that a lot of architects go on to study classicism and to practice building classical buildings, because we always need people to, for example, like make additions to historical buildings,
我的意思是，这是建筑学的经典辩论之一。但问题是，古典主义是……我的意思是，古典建筑显然很美。建筑师接受古典主义训练很重要。很多建筑师继续学习古典主义并实践建造古典建筑很重要，因为我们总是需要有人，例如，为历史建筑进行扩建，
make restorations to historical buildings, make restorations to historical buildings, to lecture on historical buildings, to work across other fields, including anthropology and archaeology, to talk about how historical buildings may have been in the past. I mean, it's just really central and important part of architecture. That being said, time always moves forward. An architecture historically and today has always been a conversation between past and present. Not a dogmatic argument between past and present, though that has happened. That's what preservation is supposed to be. It's not supposed to be like making a mothballed museum of every building. It's how do we
对历史建筑进行修复，对历史建筑进行修复，对历史建筑进行讲座，跨领域工作，包括人类学和考古学，讨论历史建筑在过去可能是什么样子。我的意思是，这确实是建筑学中非常核心和重要的部分。话虽如此，时间总是在向前推进。建筑在历史上和今天一直是过去与现在之间的对话。而不是过去与现在之间教条式的争论，尽管这种情况确实发生过。这就是保护的意义所在。它不应该是把每栋建筑都变成一个封存的博物馆。它是关于我们如何
reconcile historical architecture with contemporary needs, with contemporary economics, with contemporary politics? That's what preservation does. And modernism is included in that. The problem is not classical architecture. The problem is that there's a certain type of chud online who thinks that classical architecture
将历史建筑与当代需求、当代经济、当代政治相协调？这就是保护的作用。现代主义也包含在其中。问题不在于古典建筑。问题在于网上有一种特定的“蠢货”，他们认为古典建筑
is proof that Western society is better than other societies and that we had a beautiful Western society that was infallible, but crumbled under globalization or immigration or whatever right wing, like cryptofascist element you think ruins columns. The One and Only, Kate Wagner. You can find her writing at the new republic and McManchinHell.com. If you want to hear more from her, she's the star of episode number 232 of 99PI. It's called McManchinHell. It's one of my favorite. 99% of his bowl was produced this week by Kevin Caner's, edited by Joe Rosenberg,
证明了西方社会比其他社会更好，我们曾经拥有一个完美无缺的美丽西方社会，但它在全球化、移民或任何你认为破坏了柱子的右翼、加密法西斯主义元素下崩溃了。独一无二的凯特·瓦格纳。你可以在《新共和》（The New Republic）和McManchinHell.com上找到她的文章。如果你想听她更多的见解，她是99PI第232集的明星。那一集叫《McManchinHell》。这是我最喜欢的一集。本周的99% Invisible由Kevin Caner制作，Joe Rosenberg编辑，
mixed in tech production by Sriviusif, music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colestead, is the digital director. The rest of the team is Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Avery Truffman, Chris Barube, Vivian Lang, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of Israel is a member of Radio Topia from P.R.X. of fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join
由Sriviusif进行混音技术制作，Sean Rial配乐。Katie Mingle是我们的高级制作人，Kurt Colestead是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括Delaney Hall、Emmett Fitzgerald、Avery Truffman、Chris Barube、Vivian Lang、Sophia Klatsker，以及我Roman Mars。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心Radio Row制作。99% Invisible是来自PRX的RadioTopia成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。你可以找到这个节目并加入
discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI or on Instagram and read it too. But you can come yell at us about fonts and neo-classical architecture in mynipe.org. For PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
关于节目的讨论在Facebook上进行。你可以在Twitter上关注我@Roman Mars，关注节目@99PI，或者在Instagram和Reddit上关注。但你可以来99pi.org上就字体和新古典主义建筑对我们大喊大叫。对于PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。